The obvious approach to selecting components is to say, well what is it
the system is supposed do or compute and break that down into, into pieces.
However there are many other factors that might go into deciding
which components are going to be part of your system.
Of course, required functionality is, is most important there, but
it may also be the case that you already have some existing reusable components
from your libraries that you want to build into your system.
And that may have a important role in deciding on
the overall component structure as would the physical machine architecture,
that is the architecture providing you multiple cores in which case how can you
take advantage of those in, in breaking down your computation.
Another element you might not have thought of is your staff,
that is the people who are going to do this.
Conway's Law say's that the ultimate structure of
a system depends upon the structure of the organization building it.
So it's well to take into account that if you have three people helping you
lay out the architecture you're likely to end up with three major components.
Another important element is that for
real systems they're going to have long lifetimes.
And the trajectory of that lifetime,
the direction in which it's going to move as we saw in the Brohoff definition,
could and should strongly influence the components into which you divided.